So, I always think of calcium as a slightly
‘British element’ because the white cliffs
of Dover are made from calcium carbonate,
chalk.
Calcium is one of the Group 2, or alkaline
earth elements, it has got an atomic number
of 20.
Calcium itself is a metal but people most
commonly see it as compounds.
It is a relatively soft, sort of silvery metal
which I can actually show you. This is quite
an old sample of calcium, ok, so it is a bit
tarnished. Calcium is very, very reactive
so it quickly forms a layer. So you can see
it is kind of shining right there. It quickly
forms a layer of sort of oxides and nitrides
in the air which is what this calcium has
done here.
So many of you will have come across calcium
sulphate which is used as chalk in school,
nowadays people use dry markers and things
but there is still, we sometimes use chalk
on blackboards.
The phrase ‘in the limelight’, which I
am sure you have heard of you know, being
in television, the phrase ‘in the limelight’
actually comes from the fact that they used
to use calcium oxides and they used to aim
a very hot flame at it and make it sort of
incandescent and that is how the theatres
and sort of music halls used to be lit so
when you were in the limelight, you literally
were in a light of lime and funny enough we
use electricity now for it and for lighting
all these sorts of things but the phrase still
lasts which is quite nice.
And the compound of calcium and carbon so
called calcium carbide reacts with water to
produce acetylene, a very reactive compound
of carbon, which burns with a bright light
and in the early days of motoring, and cycling,
people use calcium carbide lights in which
they had some of this powdered calcium carbide
at the bottom of the lamp and water dripped
slowly on it to produce a gas which burnt
and gave a beam which was not nearly as bright
as one of our current headlights but was still
bright enough to get around.
And actually sort of expanding the chemistry
of this compound, this element, I think which
is slightly misunderstood and sometimes thought
of as being a bit boring, but I don’t think,
it is not boring, I think it will have a great
chemistry and hopefully very useful.
Well us chemists like to see spectacular things,
some things do cool things, I mean the transition
metals change colour you know, which is you
know, you have all these nice colours of transitions
metals, but the things that are sort of in
the main group which I mean S blocks the ones
on the left and the P block the one on the
right, don’t tend to form very coloured
compounds, it is a particular thing to the
transition metals, most of the time. So they
don’t do much in the way of colour change,
a bit boring. I mean most calcium compounds
are white. I mean ok, your bones and your
teeth are white aren't they really, but still,
we can do interesting chemistry with them,
you can make calcium compounds that can be
used as reaction catalysts which would be
great because calcium is a cheap, pretty benign
as well, so it is an ideal catalyst compared
to a lot of the expensive transition metals.